a massive explosion and new lava flows
are affecting thousands of people living
near Hawaii's Kilauea volcano time-lapse
video shows the craters pre-dawn
eruption yesterday smoke and ash shot
tens of thousands of feet into the air
some dormant fissures reactivated
yesterday and a new one the 21st opened
up mark Strassmann is in Pahoa Hawaii
mark good morning good morning a half
mile behind me that is Fisher's 17 with
all those sparks and fireworks and at
times startling explosions it's a crack
in the ground that runs about 1,400 feet
by far the biggest fissure so far and
also by far the most active for the last
five days it has just pumped out lava
and burst after burst after burst the
explosion came Thursday just after 4:00
a.m. Hawaii time captured by government
and Observatory surveillance cameras it
sent ash about 5 miles high and some 30
miles from the volcano it was relatively
short-lived as you know but clearly the
ash and the fallout is still with us
and so is the danger we're still
watching things real closely we may have
additional larger events more powerful
events in communities close to Kilauea
emergency response teams quickly handed
out 18,000 masks to protect residents
from the ash which can irritate eyes and
Airways I was hoping that they would fit
my baby
this basically silicate glass and that's
what you don't want in your mouth and
your throat in your lungs
in the two weeks since the Fisher's
first opened up lava has covered half a
square mile burned down 37 structures
and slowly destroyed everything in its
path there are now 21 fissures and
underground magma or molten rock widened
cracks in a major roadway on Thursday
officials say leaks have toxic sulfur
dioxide gas have spiked to red level
zones in some areas which can lead to
choking I think that has to do with the
fact that the air is still so we don't
have the wind moving it away so much I
want to show you a live picture of
another fissure it's a couple hundred
yards from where I'm standing this is
fissure 20d it opened up in the last 24
hours or so and you can tell this one is
also truly frightening another sobering
thought is that experts with a Hawaiian
Volcano Observatory say that this
volcano could get even more explosive at
any time sending ash and toxic gas right
into the sky bianna credible images mark
Strassmann in Hawaii thank you